Or remembering, that I said that device motion, is,
a strict super set of device orientation. Anything, you can
do with device orientation, you could do, with device
motion. However, it's going to be easier to implement things
like a compass or a joystick, using device orientation
rather than device motion. However, if you want to implement
shake to send feedback, you really need the acceleration, sensing
that device motion offers. And for a generic game controller,
rather than just a joy stick, you might find
device motion, is interesting. For example, the roll it game,
that we demonstrated at IO used the acceleration rates, from
device motion and that way you could tell what speed
the device was moving and in which direction. So,
it made it really easy to throw a ball, with
pretty good precision. One major difference, between, these two APIs,
is how often they're fired. Device orientation, is, only fired,
when the device orientation changes. For
device motion, it's fired whenever, the acceleration
changes, on the device, which includes
lateral movement. So, it fires pretty often.